uh is dave roberts on the phone line
right now the los angeles dodgers
manager how are you
uh skip you there hi i'm i'm here how
are we doing
i'm good you have a few minutes for us i
i always have a few minutes for you
i appreciate that dave because i know
that obviously lots is going on in the
world uh about what your
your team's plans are uh for this day
and obviously
uh maybe moving forward but can you walk
me through what happened
last night uh in san francisco yeah you
know what it was
it's player driven um i i think that
it's player driven i think it's
individual
[Music]
mookie and i talked and
decided you know on the heels of what's
what's going on in our country
that we needed to make a stand and and
he decided he wasn't going to play and
um for me as well
i felt the same and could help do the
same thing and i wasn't going to manage
and george lombard our coach
first base coach i felt the same way and
we brought it to the players um in the
clubhouse and kind of told them our
thoughts
and to a man they uh were all aligned
and felt playing wasn't the right thing
to do
and that's kind of where we were at and
so as
last night kind of went and we've got
two uh
games scheduled today i know that mookie
was on has been on zoom calls all
morning
with the players alliance and those guys
trying to figure out
you know what the black players in
baseball should and are gonna do
uh mookie came to the consensus that um
he wanted to play both games today and i
thought uh
that was uh amazing i'm excited about
that
and you know the thing that richie he
told me that was really cool is that
his white teammates and white ball
players around
major league baseball that chose to
stand by the side of their black
teammates
and not play to keep that unity
so to continue to keep that continuity
that unity
to play alongside them but still
understand that there's a
there's a overarching message that we
just can't lose
um you know yeah and and
clayton kershaw put out a statement he
was you know as you all know
what he was scheduled to do yesterday
and um
and and i guess walk me through your
relationship with mookie in the
conversation that you had of whatever
you can share
on this subject uh and how it did
manifest itself in
in the rest of the team following along
with sitting that game out last night
david
i think that there's a lot of uh you
know it's one of those things that
we each have to make individually and
something that we obviously
feel very strongly about that um
[Music]
racial racial injustices you know that
happen every single day
and obviously certain things have been
captured and
it hits home and mookie's talking about
family and
you know being the voice of so many
black kids his daughter
and you know i have family in texas
that have been victim of certain things
and
and so it's personal and i just think
that the education
part of it that clayton all of our
you know players just want to know more
and learn about um
has been very helpful but this is just
the beginning i think that the thing is
that these conversations are great
but then the execution of how we can
kind of get better and go from here from
there
here to there um is you know we'll see
in time but uh this is this is a start
yeah and i guess you know in a couple
minutes i have left with you because
again i know you've got
uh zooms you've got team meetings and
you know i'm sure you've got a lot of
uh conversations that you want to have
before you play two games today
so um what would you say to p i asked
this a question to chris webber in the
first hour
um you know it's it's it's going to come
like
what what what purpose did anything
serve in terms of changing
um yeah sitting one game out if that's
what it's going to be
i think yeah and i think the thing is
that understanding
that you can leverage respective
leagues nba major league baseball
to support the black lives matter
and so i think that the one game that we
sat
out um and major league baseball the
dodgers supported the giants we're here
with in san francisco
i think promoted a lot of conversations
the last 24 hours
and i think that the conversations will
still happen
and they need to happen so i just felt
that this is something
and and i say leverage richie is that
now to kind of
understand that for the industries to
support it
now we've got to come together and find
solutions
so to put a a point on it uh the dodgers
are going to be back on the field today
and that's the way you'll be in the
lineup in both cases
okay and so we spoke to justin turner
last week who said that mookie
is great at basketball and the team has
found out he's also great at golf so
you're saying he's now like an eight
nine
ten tool player after what you've just
seen
you didn't even mention like the dozen
300 uh
games that he's bowled too so
last week too um okay dave i know you
got lots going on
and uh i appreciate you calling in and
just uh
updating us on what's going on and i'd
love to get you back in the next couple
weeks when
uh baseball is uh is is mixed in with
everything
really appreciate it that's good my
friend you got it you take care that's
uh dave roberts here on the rich eisen
show
it's a lot happening right now